we could just be plugged up in my god we
could just be dumping water somewhere
not knowing where it goes
today we are getting visited by Sawyer
Hartman he's another youtuber who's
actually more of a filmmaker director
personality which is really cool there's
not a whole lot of those on YouTube I'm
really looking forward to getting to
hang out with him a little bit getting
to meet him now I think he's coming over
because he saw the VR backpack video
that we made and he's really excited to
try it out and I'm kind of worried
because I don't really have it on 2
percent up and running yet I just walked
into the studio and it was just pouring
now it's starting to dribble this one
was doing it yesterday here's a question
how many AC units do you have to install
we're chart I know abandoned I know
we're 2 out of the 3 leaked water when
you get done with them that means he's
got a 67 percent failure rate on
installation how many times have you
done this ok we have an issue there is a
pipe in the tool room that's leaking
water all over the shelves you know our
tool room
so now there's like a puddle in the
poolroom what
drip like drip drip drip drip drip drip
drip
uh-huh-huh
that's what I heard it's just fine
that's what I heard it's just it'll drip
tonight it'll stop so let's go first to
the roof to cut off the source of the
problem an AC unit leaks water because
it's an inverter and all the cool air
turns to water and I say yeah it has to
get rid of it so there's usually an exit
pipe that you either filter into a
garden or into the sewer or whatever
good that look like it are you going
somewhere
well what do you think that's going into
our tool room that's this is yeah this
has to be it these air conditioning
units are supposed to last for years the
solution being let's run piping without
securing it across the roof to a place
we don't know where it goes without
actually clamping it down hey man he's
only been doing it for 30 years that's
the thing dude I don't that's what I
don't get my dad was a was a union
carpenter for like 25 years
and it's this kind of [ __ ] that when he
came home when I was a child and he was
upset and I didn't understand why it's
because of this kind of [ __ ]
now I get it so say I'm still in Iceland
and Jake and I have a whole bunch of
work we got to do to try to get these
bigger projects off the ground Swede
some help to pull off the next video now
gave has a bit of an animation
background and run obviously has a great
visual background and Peter no one knows
what his background is actually like but
the thing is we asked them to get
together and design the SAP motion
action scene for the next video here you
see what they come up with I'm sure
it'll be a mishmash of a bunch of
different cool ideas
okay so from the ground I can see both
walls where the crossbeam meets the wall
we want to find like a cross between
enough resolution but also enough
coverage so we want to shoot this whole
entire thing in here and we want to do
it with no visual effects at least no
visible VFX you had a good idea of
actually attaching some sort of dolly
system to the Raptor up there so we can
move the camera but it'd be way easier
if we don't have to move the camera at
all just shoot wide enough to cover
everything
sorry partner
good Steve but yeah like I mostly make
narratives I made a feature film last
year but 88 days ago now I decided to
make a film every single day for 391
days to 291 yes everything's my 27th
birthday okay so now that's kind of like
taking over my life what's your schedule
like we need to put a video every day
depends what I'm doing I always try to I
try to structure my three-act stories
get like a good channel in the morning
find the meat of the story in the
afternoon and if you make a wrap-up at
night so I really enjoy showing people
VR for the first time I've gotten to do
it quite a bit now which is great and
pretty much always people's minds are
blown it doesn't matter if you are my
mom who has never touched videogames
before in her life or if you are when I
friends play video games all the time it
all has the same reaction watching
people yell and scream and laugh and
take out their headset and like realize
they're still in the real world and like
come to terms with whether or not they
know if they're actually in the real
world that's the best part holy crap
it's so it's so weird to like yeah yeah
that's really yeah dude that was so
amazingly cool what's happening
apparently their air conditioning guys
messed up again to give it to me of
course to fix it clean it whatever needs
to be done my concern is that the water
has gotten into the walls so I'd be
interested to see what Gabe comes back
with if he doesn't dry it all out then
we're gonna have mold get in there and
that's not a good thing you pretty much
cut it before it caused any real damage
if Ren hadn't just walked by and heard
the water falling as I would displace a
little bit flooded since he caught it I
think just when I started that saved me
from a lot of work yeah well I don't
understand why is he using copper pipe
of all metals what's the problem with
copper copper is expensive
we could just be dumping water somewhere
not knowing where it goes okay now what
do we do with you and like look at how
much unnecessary did he charge us for
all that piping no he did yeah it's just
sipped I'd like that that's that's his
five-year solution because it because
there's no more money in the budget then
why didn't he just quote me higher like
I want it done right I don't want it
done super cheap so I mean the gist of
it is that like all right this guy's
walking his dog super soldier comes out
of nowhere and then a fight begins when
we can choreograph that how we want but
in order to realistically figure out
what we're gonna be doing we have to
know our balance and our founds would be
where the field of view of the camera
ends and we now know that with this set
up I think we can get the entire room I
think now that we have a pretty good
idea of how we're going to be filming
this stuff we should figure out what
we're going to be filming so start
storyboard took the words right out of
my mouth fish sex